some of the oldest windmills in the  world can be found on the gusty border  of northern iran and afghanistan  [Music]  is a city located in the coruscant  province of iran the city name was  previously nish tufan translating to  storm sting which is appropriate for  this windy city  a 65-foot wall blocks the intense scale  force winds and the top of that wall are  around two dozen vertical axis windmills  they are made from clay straw and wood  and it's estimated that they were  constructed over 1 000 years ago  [Music]  the windmills still function today and  can be used to milk grain into flour  in 2002 stefan was recognized as a  national heritage site by iran's  cultural heritage department  in the hopes that it will be around for  thousands of years to come  [Music]  you